we've been talking about the candid
conversation prince harry and megan had
with oprah last night including
some of the moments that did not air
last night oprah joins us now to discuss
oprah hay
let's pick it up right where we left off
before the commercial break
where harry wants to make it very clear
it seems that he did not blindside the
queen we left
i don't know if you could hear it with a
bite where you said doesn't the queen
get to do what the queen wants to do he
had made several attempts
to see his grandmother
yes and i think uh that was such an
important story
uh to be shared last night uh
in the process of trying to um edit
this three hours and 20 minutes
down to an hour and 25 minutes i said to
my team the most
important question to be answered here
at the end of this show will be
why did they leave and i think the
stories about being
blindsided uh blindsiding the queen were
very very damaging to them
and also hurtful because they understood
very clearly
that there had been months and months of
preparation before they
actually moved to canada and and and
truthfully there was a statement by the
queen her majesty the queen
on january 18th in which she said uh
following many months of conversations
and more recent discussions i am pleased
that together
we have found constructive and
supportive way forward for my grandson
and his family
so the queen on january 18th actually
said that there had been months of
conversation but in spite of that
there were still all of those stories
about blindsiding the
queen blindsided that's why the details
are very happy that that is why the
details are that's why the details
tabloids print stuff that they know is
false and have been told
isn't true but oprah it's also
the the question remains why the queen
cannot dictate who she sees and when she
sees them
and it seems to come back to something
that megan pointed out early that
there's the family
and then there's the institution and you
were constantly trying to probe the
difference between the two
what did you take away from that
i took away from that that there are as
harry just indicated there are people
surrounding
the family who are advisors to the
family who have
been there for a long time and that's a
part of the
hierarchical structure and those people
have a lot of
influence and also input
you get i mean you mentioned last night
oprah that you watch the crown i do too
you get a sense of that in the crown
that
that actually there is almost kind of
like a deep state within the monarchy
that actually
runs the monarchy but i wanted to ask
you we had tina brown on earlier
who said that this interview is like
kryptonite for the royal family and i'm
sure
harry and megan when they agreed to have
this conversation with you
knew it was not going to make their
relationship with the royal family
any easier why do you think
they agreed to do it
oh i think they agreed to do it wanted
to do it
we're ready to do it because
when you have been lied about
for a series of years i think
anybody you can understand this
if in your own office or in your own
family somebody is saying things about
you that are not true
and how hurtful that is or if you're
online
and you read the comments from something
that somebody has said about you
and you continue to see those comments
how hurtful that is so imagine that for
over a period of months and years
and you know that it isn't true i think
the most important thing for them you
know before i do any interview
i have a conversation with uh whoever
i'm interviewing and ask tell me what
your intention is
and i will tell you what my intention is
and let's see if we can align those two
because
i don't want you to finish an interview
and at the end of the interview say i
wish i had said
and uh but let's talk let's talk about
wait the jaw dropping moment the first
one
about the color of the baby's skin and
you you asked harry about it when he
came out he did not tell you who it was
do you did you all have another
conversation about it because that was
something that
there's a big guessing game all around
the world who was it who wasn't who
wasn't i thought it was very
touching that harry still is choosing to
protect the identity
of whoever that was yes and
he did not share the identity with me
but he wanted to make sure that i knew
and if i had an opportunity to share it
that it was
not his grandmother mother nor his
grandfather
that were a part of those conversations
that it was not his grandmother and
prince philip he said yes was not his
grandfather
neither his grand grandmother nor
grandfather
were part of those conversations he did
not tell me who were a part of those
conversations
as you can see i tried to get that
answer
on camera and off all right oprah stay
with us
you have more never before seen clips
for us including megan talking
about her own family